Google Gemini new free updates are
insane. Google just dropped something
huge, and I mean huge. We're talking new
image tools, video tools, music tools,
AI agents, and even AI built into your
phone. All free, all inside Gemini. And
honestly, this might change everything.
Let me break it all down for you right
now. So, Google didn't just drop one
update, they dropped like seven at the
same time. And nobody is really talking
about how big this actually is because
this isn't just some small little
feature thing. This is Google saying,
"Hey, we're building an entire AI world
and you get to use it for free." So, let
me walk you through every single update.
And trust me, by the end of this, you're
going to look at Google Gemini.
Completely different. Let's start with
the first one. And this one is wild.
Google just announced something called
Nano Banana 2. Yeah, that's the actual
name. Nano Banana 2. And it's their
brand new image model. But here's what
makes it different from everything else
out there. This thing uses real world
knowledge to make images. So it actually
understands what stuff looks like in the
real world. It's not just guessing. It
knows. On top of that, it can write text
in multiple languages inside images. And
if you've ever tried to get AI to put
text on an image, you know how bad that
usually goes. This one actually does it
right. The prompt understanding is way
better, too. So when you tell it what
you want, it actually listens. and the
images it makes are more accurate to
what you ask for. This is Google going
head-to-head with OpenAI and MidJourney.
And from what we're seeing, they're not
messing around, though. Now, here's
where it gets even more interesting.
Inside the Gemini app, Google just added
templates. And not just for images, they
added templates for video with Veo 3.1,
templates for music with LIA 3, and
templates for images with Nano Banana 2.
So, now you don't need to be some
prompting genius to make cool stuff. You
just pick a template, follow the guide,
and boom, you've got content. This makes
Gemini way more beginner friendly, and
it tells you something important. Google
isn't just building a chatbot anymore.
They're building a creator tool, a
full-on creative platform, and that's a
big deal. Hey, if we haven't met
already, I'm the digital avatar of
Julian Goldie, CEO of Goldie Agency.
Whilst he's helping clients get more
leads and customers, I'm here to help
you get the latest AI updates. Julian
Goldie reads every comment, so make sure
you comment below. All right, let's keep
going because we're just getting
started. The next update is Flow by
Google and this one got a massive
redesign. Google is turning Flow into
what they're calling an AI creative
studio. So, think about it like this.
Instead of jumping between 10 different
apps to make content, you do it all in
one place. You build workflows. You set
up content pipelines. You use multiple
AI tools at once. And some people think
this could even get agentpowered
creative automation down the line. That
means the AI doesn't just help you make
stuff, it makes stuff for you
automatically. This is Google going
after tools like Runway and Canva. And
honestly, the way they're building this
out, it could be a real threat. And
speaking of agents, here's where things
get really futuristic. Google's tool
called Opal just got a new thing called
an agent step. And this is important
because before workflows in Opel were
pretty static. You set them up. They ran
the same way every time. Now with agent
step, your workflows can think. They can
respond to what's happening. They can
make decisions on the fly. They become
interactive. This is Google pushing hard
into AI agents. And this is the
direction the whole industry is going.
AI that doesn't just answer questions.
AI that actually does things for you.
Remember this one because agents are
going to be everywhere very soon. Now,
let me tell you about the next update.
And if you're into music or content
creation, pay attention. Google Labs
just brought in something called
Producer AI. This is a music creation
tool. And when you combine it with LIA,
which is Google's music model, you've
now got a serious music stack inside
Google's ecosystem. Think about what
Google has now. Image generation, video
generation, music generation, workflow
tools, AI agents, all under one roof,
all connected. That's not a feature
update. That's an ecosystem. And that
matters way more than any single tool.
Now, here's something that I think is
going to fly under the radar, but is
actually one of the biggest moves Google
made this week. But before I get into
that, if you want to learn how to
actually use AI tools like Google Gemini
to automate your business and get more
customers, you need to check out my AI
profit boardroom. This is where I show
you step by step how to use these exact
tools to scale. Whether you're using
Gemini for content, for workflows, or
for automation, this is the place to
learn how to do it right. Link is in the
description and the comments. Go check
it out. All right, back to it. Google
just made Gemini AI literacy training
available to 6 million teachers in the
United States. 6 million that's K
through 12 and higher education. And
this is massive because when you train 6
million teachers on your AI tool, you're
not just getting users, you're building
the foundation. You're making sure the
next generation grows up using Gemini.
That's a long gameplay. And it's smart.
Really smart. This is Google going
directly after Microsoft who's been
pushing C-pilot into schools. And
honestly, whoever wins the education
space is going to have a huge advantage
for years to come. Now, the last update,
and this one hits different because it's
about your phone. Google just announced
new AI features that are going to be
built directly into the Samsung Galaxy
S26 powered by Gemini. And these aren't
just little gimmick features. We're
talking scam detection. So, the AI can
spot when someone is trying to scam you
on a call or in a message. We're talking
task automation. So the AI can do stuff
on your phone for you. And the best
part, all of this runs on the device,
not in the cloud, on the actual phone.
That means it's faster, it's more
private, and it works even when your
internet is slow or you're offline. This
is Google taking Gemini out of the
browser and putting it in your pocket.
And that's where AI needs to be if it's
going to be truly useful every day. So,
let me zoom out for a second because I
think a lot of people are going to miss
the big picture here. This week, Google
didn't just update Gemini. They expanded
it across everything. Images with Nano
Banana 2, video with Veo 3.1 templates,
music with LIA 3 and producer AI,
creative workflows with the flow
redesign, AI agents with the Opel agent
step, education with 6 million teachers
getting trained, and mobile with
ondevice AI in the Samsung Galaxy S26.
That's seven major moves in one week
across seven different categories. This
isn't a product update. This is Google
building an AI operating system for
everything. Creativity, education,
phones, automation, all of it. And
here's what I think is a real question
everyone should be asking. Is Google
pulling ahead of Open AI right now?
Because when you look at the full
picture, it's hard to argue they're not
at least catching up fast. Open AAI has
amazing models. No question. But Google
has the ecosystem. They've got the
hardware. They've got the education
pipeline. They've got the creative
tools. And they've got distribution that
nobody else can match. So yeah, this
week was big, way bigger than most
people realize. Now, if you want to stay
on top of all of this and actually use
these tools to grow your business, you
need to be inside my AI profit
boardroom. This is where I break down
exactly how to use AI tools like Google
Gemini to automate your workflows, build
systems that run without you, and get
more customers on autopilot. We're
talking templates, walkthroughs, live
sessions, everything you need to
actually put this stuff into action.
Because knowing about these updates is
one thing, but using them to scale your
business is a completely different game.
And that's what the AI profit boardroom
is built for. So if you watched this
video and thought, I want to actually do
something with all this, then this is
your next step. Link is in the
description and the comments. Go join
right now while it's fresh in your head.
And one more thing before you go, if you
want the full process, the SOPs, and
over a 100 AI use cases just like this
one, you need to join the AI success
lab. This is our free AI community and
it is packed with value. You'll get all
the video notes from every single video
I put out. You'll get access to our
community of 38,000 members who are all
using AI to level up. And people in
there are sharing what's working, asking
questions, helping each other out. It's
one of the best AI communities on the
internet. And it won't cost you a thing
to join. Links are in the comments and
the description. Go sign up, introduce
yourself, and start connecting with
people who are actually doing this stuff
every single day. Make sure you like
this video, subscribe, and drop a
comment below. Julian reads every single
one. I'll see you in the next one.